podría haberse evitado el secuestro del
periodista francés Oliver dubois una
investigación llevada a cabo por varios
medios de comunicación franceses entre
ellos El Diario Liberación afirma que
podría verse impedido el documento
señala con el dedo al ejército francés y
más concretamente a sus fuerzas de la
operación barcán en el sahel el grupo
operativo había sido informado en abril
de 2021 de que el reportero tenía
previsto entrevistarse con el líder
yihadista abdalá a galvacalle el jefe de
nuserrat al islam filial de al qaeda en
el magreb islámico Olivier llevaba
varios meses en contacto con un
intermediario conocido como kather que
colaboraba con el grupo yihadista pero
también suministraba información de
inteligencia a los militares franceses
según la investigación las fuerzas de
barcán tenían la intención de aprovechar
la entrevista para localizar a
galvacalle por razones de seguridad
abandonaron Esos planes en el último
momento pero los militares no
desplegaron tropas para impedir El
secuestro de dubois falló el ejército en
su operación de inteligencia según una
investigación interna la situación no se
había evaluado correctamente
no hubo Mala conducta por parte de la
fuerza abarcan pero no se tuvo
suficientemente en cuenta la
sensibilidad del asunto para llevar a
cabo una acción disuasoria con respecto
al periodista estas precarias
condiciones de seguridad llevaron a
Liberación a no financiar en su momento
el reportaje de Oliver dubá quien
acabaría secuestrado pasando más de 700
días en cautiverio por su parte el
Ministerio francés de asuntos exteriores
y el Estado Mayor del ejército han
declinado a ser comentarios sobre las
revelaciones